encore un ton a pas mettre un chat
dehors pas vrai niveau n'aime pas la
pluie 1 elle préfère les capsules de les
confiner alors reste avec moi je vais
t'expliquer pourquoi les chats n'aiment
pas l'eau le chat est une espèce
originaire du moyen-orient et d'afrique
du nord des régions très aride où les
points d'eau sont extrêmement rares
hormis pour boire le chat a donc su se
passer d'eau l'origine c'est un milieu
qu'il ne connaît pas d'où sa grande
méfiance quand il s'en approche
ou quand il pleut alors qu en fait l'eau
ne présente aucun danger pour les chats
d'ailleurs ils savent tous nagé d'autres
félins originaires de régions tropicales
le jaguar ou le tigre n'éprouve quant à
eux aucune appréhension
il se baigne échasses volontiers dans
les rivières
tenez il y a même des chats qui adore
l'eau le véhicule par exemple ou bien le
tueur de vannes celui ci précisément
parce qu'il est originaire des rives du
lac de van à l'est de la turquie et
qu'il a donc toujours vécu au contact de
l'eau si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
celle des jours précédents en cliquant
sur le côté gauche
je réalise une nouvelle chaque jour
alors pour éviter d'en louper et bien
abonnez vous et activer la petite cloche
à demain et n'oubliez pas nous sommes
confinés
mais en restant bien on va prendre là